[Music]
when Jan Foster comes face-to-face for
the sons imaginary playmate the world
strength upside down he seeks the power
of ancient rituals hoping to find the
strength to save her son
and cast out a demon held that in
possessing him
[Applause]
[Music]
if
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey everybody is episode 50 yeah whoo
that's a good one too this is another
hopping show yeah we know how much you
guys like those what else I like doing a
demon child even probably one of our
favorite episodes just because it's so
really what makes it the best I think is
that kids like that kid is so
entertaining and like all his facial
expressions are really super funny and
he's peeing on everything he pees on
many things in this episode um we were
actually yeah I was little I was like
trying to think of doing something like
super special like for the 50th episode
but then I didn't think of it was just a
number I guess so we'll just say that so
we'll that's the only specialty we don't
have to worry about the network's
bondage anymore yeah sure that's good
yeah so um have to worry about going
through that well yeah what's the house
cleaning well if you listen to last
week's show like I said we're not doing
we're not on Project Entertainment
Network anymore but if you still want
just the audio version of the podcast
you can get it on we have a wordpress
blog that's called 13 o'clock podcasts
all of the episodes since the beginning
are on there because I've been posting
them on there the whole time you can get
them from there you can get them from
archive.org we have a page they're
called 13 o'clock podcasts that you and
you can download it directly from there
now I did set up a new feed burner so
hopefully if you are listening on itunes
or on any of the other ones and
hopefully it will update if it doesn't
maybe just do a search I was actually
having problems with iTunes before with
it not updating like it was three or
four weeks behind even when we were on
projects Entertainment Network you know
a couple of you have let me know that
that they're a little bit behind so
hopefully we'll get that all sorted out
but we'll see how it goes yeah so the
audio version is still there it's just
you know it's at one less place that's
all yeah and the YouTube show like I
said it's just going to be exactly the
same so no changes there it's still
going to go up on Tuesday every week
just like normal and so the other thing
that we want to shout out is our patreon
I picked up another favor yeah this
which is really good and if you are
interested in like a lot of our stuff
and just kind of want to hear some extra
[ __ ] we have like a bunch of extra stuff
yeah we do that bonus material um posted
on there yeah we had a kind of a funny
one where where we talked about various
troop saw about haunting we had one
where we talked about project
entertainment we had one where we talked
about I had one of me reading the short
story I have had a teacher of my new
true-crime book faithful villain that's
up there yeah we got some more stuff we
going to put up there yeah we're going
to put up some more stuff as the week's
go on so you know you support the show
yeah so if you support the show on
patreon even it doesn't have to be five
dollars even any amount will get you
access at least to our yeah all I a cute
little care dollar yeah so that'll be
fine don't worry about that and let's
see what else let's also mention again
Sookie Empire yeah at the end of October
October 27 28 29 so weekend before
Halloween and it's down here in Orlando
I think it's probably the Orange County
Convention Center that's where it was
last year we're going to be at that and
we're going to be doing some of the
panels and we're going to get selling
books and all this other kind of stuff
so we'll be there so come and say hi and
smile at us and have some booze with us
and whatnot unseen hand selling really
well everybody's like in that book
audiobooks so I'm good
also 13 o'clock in minutes imagine that
if you liked this show please subscribe
to our other channel 13 o'clock and
lives and I just put up a new I just put
up a new video creepiest disappearances
5 it Acree pieces yeah I have a chance
look oh yeah yeah it's like missing
personal cases so yeah I just put that
up a couple days ago so that's a new one
you might want to go check that out and
the only other thing I want to mention
is my blogs got acid Hellfire which I've
been actually updating pretty good the
last few weeks um usually with more
newer horror movie reviews I just put up
one the other day that was the movies
creep and they look like people so if
you want to read about or movies old
ones new ones and then I got books and
stuff on there too reviews funny stuff
then go check out my blog it's just
goddess of Hellfire calm and I think
that's pretty much all the housekeeping
we had to get out of where I good yeah
okay let's get right to the episode okay
so walking
yeah and child demon child or I hook us
up with a Jeff
well this is actually a season 2 episode
this is one of the rare ones where the
people only wanted to be on the show if
they were in silhouette right so you've
never really seen their faces we you can
know you can hear their voices they're
southerners you can tell that it's
supposed to be taking place in Kentucky
Kentucky and there's a pretty strong
drawls in there so yeah you know whether
the thing actually took place in
Kentucky you probably did maybe they
change the town or whatever the couple
at the center of it on the show were
named Dale and Jan Foster but I'm
assuming that's not their real name if
they wanted their identity so you
through your research you were never
able to actually identify who this
family is what their names are right now
there are any other secondary sources of
information this is the only not yeah
not that I ever saw all right that's not
what that's always different difficult
when you only have one source of
information yeah that happens a lot with
some of these uh you know haunting
episodes I see you know other than the
ones that were like kind of famous cases
like the Dybbuk box and all that
although that was terrible what this
wasn't you know where there's no other
like no one wrote a book about it
there's no pair of psychologists
involved there's nothing like that and
like I said we don't know these people's
real names I don't even know if that's
really the town is there from right I
think all they said was Western Kentucky
which might be accurate now but yeah so
it's Dale and Jan Foster they have two
kids now they have a daughter who's 16
and her name is Pamela she doesn't
really factor into the story all that
much and then they have a five-year-old
son named Cody yes and we love Cody yeah
Cody is the best part of the
thermosiphon see when you're dealing
with a case like this and the video is
the only source then it's going to be up
to new Dominion pitchers to tell you
this story there's no way to verify it
so this is all we have is just a video
well yeah okay so we're not really doing
so much a debunking we're just kind of
having fun with with the episode yeah
you can't really debunk it because
there's not enough information there but
that's not the point the point is we're
going to talk about this and give us
give you guys our opinions about what is
being depicted yeah that's a good video
and and I hope so and I also have to say
that yet again and this seems to happen
a lot with episodes that we cover on
this show yeah
a guy who plays the dad is get to wreck
oh man it's raccoon mange doesn't have
any lives in this one yeah he's really
yeah he's really not kind of beyond
editing in this one yeah but I swear to
get why does that happen
do we just like specifically like that
guy or episodes of that guys and there's
just something about you know it seems
like pretty much every weasel his way
into the good episode oh it's our
favorite because if you haven't seen
like because we've seen pretty much I
think we did pretty much every episode
of on thing ever film for the first left
firstly the first 70 days yeah and most
of them multiple times and if you see
them enough times you start to notice
that they use a lot of the same actors
oh my gosh our turn the same shower
curtain the same bugs yeah the same you
know because the set design I guess is
the same I guess they film it at
different houses at least the exterior
yeah did this different places I can but
yeah I mean they do seem to make an
effort to film it in the actual like
near where the actual thing took place
but um it's not going to be the exact
same house obviously because I mean when
we did and we did a haunting in Florida
that did look like Delta in Florida
because yeah I'm from but I know the
house they're talking about well that
wasn't it that wasn't it
but you know what the house is the can't
show on in that area yeah still like
that area you do seem to make an effort
to make it kind of close in that same
neighborhood and I guess it's whatever
empty one they can run out or whatever
the address and then once I got there I
said that's not that's not the house
that their show yeah and you drive a
little just up the block a little bit
you go that's a hot fish yeah and now
what we like those people that live
there have all these awesome fans get on
their lawn out of my yard one day now
one thing I've noticed that they do a
lot and I think they did it on this
episode to the demon child one is that
the houses that they show these families
living in always like way nicer than I
imagined the real houses are yeah
because okay now I don't know if this is
their real jobs or not because like I
said they wanted to stay anonymous now
the guy was supposedly worked for the
post office in some capacity and she was
like a delivery driver
for UPS or FedEx or something like that
but they live in a house look like a
monument yeah it looks like I mean even
down here where the housing is not
terribly expensive that would be almost
a million dollar house yeah I think so I
mean that was a gigantic brick out we
depend on any location
yeah houses like that in certain
forgotten towns now yeah that's true
that doesn't make any sense when you see
them you're like what why is that there
yeah yeah I mean there's no money around
in this neighborhood have that get built
well there used to be a long time well
back in the old way yeah okaaaaay moved
but maybe that's what it was maybe it is
is that when you find those things if
you try to community if you try to find
who owns it the LA times are not being
used try to find who owns that you were
to ask how much in work they wanted a
ridiculous amount of money for it you're
like how's the person who's supposed to
live in this area can come over like
online yeah you know wealthy not like us
except Detroit you can find a whole sky
scrubber in Detroit for 100 hundred
bucks yeah you want to go be Batman
abide you want to be bad the problem is
Detroit is that once you saw on the
dotted line you've now agreed to redo
redo all the electricity all the
plumbing so you're putting eight million
dollars into this thing yeah true so
that's what he buys them no not really
as much of a bargain
no it's officially but okay so this
story like I said really the first thing
that seemed amiss was that this couple
they had a nanny that stayed in the
house and looked after Cody during the
day because I was he was I guess he's
only five suing barely old enough to go
to school yet
so this nanny kind of takes the mother
aside and says something like you know
he's been acting really bratty pretty
much I mean like he's been swearing and
like using what is quote unquote
unspeakable variables and I was like
well he spoke them yeah obviously how is
equal were like it somehow Lovecraft it
must have been could use somebody Nicole
I guess it was and so yeah and said he
was acting role real bratty and real
strange and stuff like that and I think
that she implied that when she had taken
the kid to the park
she says the kid was there playing with
his trucks or whatever and then the
swing looked like it kind of started
going by itself and then she said the
kids started talking
to somebody in the swing that was
obviously not there yeah so there's an
imaginary friend she says okay so the
kid has an imaginary friend and it's
suddenly acting like a tiny [ __ ] yeah
and I love this like this is their nanny
right like this woman that comes to
their house of watches their kids yeah
and the mom is like oh well I'll talk to
the kid and stuff and the nanny's like
we'll see that you do soo-ji I'm like
all right Mary Poppins and a boy I don't
know I just thought that was everyone
it's like not even her kids when I was
sure what year this is it's never given
yeah I mean saying it's the 70s you
think well I know the woman was kind of
older yeah at the time of the interview
I could tell by her silhouette in her
voice I was probably about 60 and she
was talking about I guess and during a
time when she was in her 20s so I'm
saying that this was made in the 70s
although they didn't film it to look
like that
now that it'd be kind of expensive to
mix a good period they never had they
never really mentioned the that's true I
usually don't go a lot I mean because
even when we I mean we did haunting in
summer winds that was set in what like
the late sixties or seventies right yeah
they did kind of have the people look
sort of seventies ish but they didn't
really go whole hog with yeah fact the
way the girl was dressed she was wearing
a white belt she actually looked Indy
yeah but it looks modern day with otter
day but I just didn't match up a woman
was that she had to been about sixty
yeah probably yeah well maybe well maybe
she was in her 30s when she had to fit
yeah 30 years okay there's no tellin ya
so we don't really don't wanna not
Hospital put a date on this right so so
Kody has an imaginary friend right and
that's you know kind of was like well
whatever you know and you should exactly
like a tool and that happened okay
prepare yourself because not much
actually physically happen well now I
feel like that happens a lot too on the
on the episodes that we talk about when
I go to write the rectum whatever the
end of allure like the outline of my
four things happen yeah and yet somehow
they made it like a 48 minute episode
you have to kinda in my
yeah pretty good now I do notice that
and they do this a lot too but like at
the end like the last 20 minutes 15 20
minutes of the episode that all be like
exorcism yeah so no but it'll basically
be they film somebody walking around a
house but really shoulders yeah and then
they filmed it all crazy like with a
shaky camp with like mochi have a loving
she'll a feather yeah and like a shining
lights to the windows don't look like
something was happening there shaking
the camera yeah look scared look scared
over your shoulder decide give it to me
hahaha I like your fear yeah but yeah so
big record beginning after that so after
the kid acting like an [ __ ] and
having an imaginary friend okay fine now
the next thing that happens is actually
the 16 year old daughter yeah
they show her and she's in her bedroom
at night and she starts hearing
something under the bed yes now the
first thing they do is one of the kids
one of the cat fake-outs which is kind
of your your horror standard there it
was the cat it was the cat like under
the bed making noise which I can relate
to because our kitten does the same
thing her see that's why there could be
a ghost in our room all this time and I
would never know because I wake up in
the middle of the night and I hear a
bunch of noise and I just assume it's
akin to everything she ends up running
into her mom's room saying that she
heard something Kwan's scratching on the
wall that's the first because she was
she takes the cat in the bed and then
the cast there but then she served
filter hearing scratching like it the
walls of the doors nothing like that
that's what she said yeah she jumps in
bed a mom and dad at 16 years of age
which I thought was very weird and then
the weirdest the weirdest thing ever and
I took a screenshot of this specifically
so I could put it in a YouTube video
because I thought it was so creepy
what is that so the 16 year old daughter
is sleeping in the bed with the parents
and then the mom gets up to go take a
shower to go to work in the morning and
leaves the 16 year old side of the dad
in bed together and they did a shot of
it yeah well hey you know what we don't
have any daughters who have any kids so
maybe that's just you know I don't know
I guess I'll be haters July I was just
thinking back to when I was 16 and how
weird that was
yeah what the [ __ ] where'd my mom go I
was like I don't want to be in bed of my
dad that's creepy I just thought it was
weird that they went out of their way to
show if she would not okay while she was
that scared she was that scared she
wasn't caught so the mom gets up and
goes take a shower going to work or
whatever now she's in the shower and she
hears something in the bathroom yeah
that's right and she thinks now on the
show they shows like a shadow on the
curtain or wherever shooting say she saw
that she said she heard something in the
bathroom and she thought it was Cody and
so she like opens the curtain where
there's nobody there yeah but she sees a
footprint yeah she sees like a footprint
like the shampoo bottle is falling off
the side of the tub which is not that
weird and she sees a footprint like in
the rug right wet footprint well it look
like a shoe footprint yeah right it was
a shoe foot yeah black yeah like a dirty
footprint yeah right so she goes to the
kids bedroom to think that who think
they think of it's the kid his shows his
shoes weren't on they were a long top of
the bed yeah he still had his jammies
jammies on he was talking to man and he
was talking to me man because in case we
didn't mention that's the name the name
of the happy it nested her dear friend
so what's his name he's a man he doesn't
have the other name no his name's man
that at the end of that his name is man
I think it would have been actually
funnier if his name was kid yeah
[Laughter]
but his name is man so yeah yeah he's
playing with the cars and she's she said
something to him what'd she say to him
and he said something bands that said I
could understand well now at this point
I think she's just like hey why don't
you um get why don't you get ready for
school or doesn't like that effort and
then the kid gets up and stomps with
purpose
okay smother and he's like I want to go
to school I don't want to play with math
yeah but he takes his clothes and shoes
are folded on the bed and he just sweeps
it off - that's right they get into a
big pissing match and it's funny cuz you
can tell the little boys up almost
laughing his ass off I chose the actress
that is what he's rolling back laughs
what is so funny about this kid and like
I said I went through this episode and
took like a whole bunch of screenshots
of this kid's face just because it was
kids expressions crack me up you can
tell that he's trying to have a tantrum
but that he's also trying really hard
not to laugh yeah so like he's trying to
look really mean and pissed off yeah and
he gets like this deadpan look with it
on his face with this curled small and
he looks just like a little baby version
of that guy if you've ever seen James
Bond Casino Royale el-sheikh bread guy
with a bigger black person okay looks
like the one gray I asked are you can
bleed tears and we sitting there at the
poker table with his face all snarled up
and everything it up it does a badass
movie I ever saw I love because you know
Roy that did look like he wanted to kill
you you know that kid does you got to
put a shot of that guy in the video okay
I'll have to find on it but he looks
shutting from side by side that little
boy LC prick they look they look exactly
like talking on kids hair
GBL cheap prick but yeah so that's like
the funniest part too is because you can
tell the kids try not to laugh and then
the actress is also trying to be mad at
images also trying not to laugh and they
didn't do another take it's kind of
subtle but you can tell yes so basically
what ends up happening is that the kid
just starts acting more and more like a
total growling it's like he just doesn't
want to do anything he always wants to
play with man they kind of hear him like
he's awake at night and he's like
talking and [ __ ] like that alright so
he's in the kitchen and like his mom's
trying to get him to breakfast and stuff
and she's telling raccoon man hey kid
has a imaginary friend isn't making him
act like a brat is not funny and sudden
he's like okay whatever he's not really
finances yeah and so then the kid comes
in the kitchen and she's like hey eat
your cereal Oh Wyatt Sarila wanna play
with man yeah and then she gets all
upset about it and [ __ ] like that starts
asking more questions about man and then
he actually tells the story man yeah so
this at this point I don't think the the
dad because they did they only talk to
the dad like the real bad yeah for only
once or twice yeah he's like I didn't
really know what to sign you know
they're getting all up saying yeah he
did he talked just like that I can do
that I'm from Mississippi NOLA
you know how they are you know I thought
he was going up like I don't know change
you know what animal boy do you know
when they're five she's getting all
upset and again I mean edges and we
actually kind of talked about this on
one of the extra things that we did on
our patreon that's kind of a real common
trope on housing is like the men are
just like whatever man I wanted women I
didn't want to deal with it having women
are yeah yeah no I did not see it he but
she wants she want to get a very good it
turns out so she starts asking him about
man now Cody says that man is actually a
little boy and he's six years old yeah
and she says that man came from behind
the park where the lake is
what she did he said he said oh yeah he
came from behind the park deep in the
ground right and that a stranger took
him from his mommy yeah and did terrible
things to him yeah and the little boy
cried and cried and dreams my body but
his mommy never came and his mommy never
found him and he never saw his mommy
again
yes and so at this point like his mom is
later gonna is yeah it's tripping out
and like it's you know is man dead and
he says yeah man's good so now they're
thinking okay well now there's like a
malevolent little done kids haunting our
house and making our kid act like a
total dick last time yeah it gets worse
- yeah it's not good again the dad is
just kind of like blowing it off like
whatever kids do weird you have they do
yeah I'm showing off I'm chilling here
always fans ever bad guys daughter dead
children my grandpa did
good chillin but the mom thinks there
might be something more to it
so her and the daughter go to you know
the records office or whatever and they
kind of look up old newspapers on the
microfiche seeing if there was some kind
of unsolved child murder or some kind of
[ __ ] well they don't find anything so we
don't know if there's any corroboration
that there was no child murder that
seemed to correspond so she said like
over the over the course of the next few
weeks or however long it was you know
Cody became more kind of introspective
not intersected but he didn't want to
talk to them anymore like he was just
stay in his room and cause of the man
and introverted introverted yeah that's
I meant and [ __ ] like that so at that
point there is no mention on this show
anywhere that they saw any kind of
psychological counseling for this child
no you know anything else a little me
that you know I'm crazy no calling any
and showing this she knew because I
remember evidently everybody that
Rosanna haunting knows know yes should I
kick or an Indian shaman which is
amazing
yeah I don't we don't know any we do a
lot of people yeah west coast you know
we hunt ha ha
hunt deer he gonna be Indian shame and
you know that's a Indian magic yeah
they're around there so she so she
consults this Indian shaman that she
does yeah he just didn't the way he's
presented you know you got it he's got
it was a braid we've got something tied
around his like a headband yeah great
depends off you know this yeah although
you know what when he answered they did
not play Indian music today you're right
that was the only one we haven't done
that yeah
not that I noticed although I not have
to watch I don't because I don't
remember I don't remember out of that
yeah because you notice that kind of
yeah but um musical I understand how
their claims my mind review this video I
don't you do it just could that pretty
shut up your model Wow getting me to
believe in heaven God approved yeah this
man come in yeah whoa right yeah so it
didn't happen the Sun the Native
American just came to and he didn't have
a soundtrack yeah it was kind of a just
and rest but he basically told them well
they said we think there's like a ghost
of a dead kid and it's kind of like
possessing the kid or at least taking
the kids soul away I don't know what
they thought it was doing but it was
making their kid act like a brat or
whatever so he said well you know you
have to do the cleansing and the sage
burning and yadda yadda but he's like
but I can't do it the owner of the house
was gonna do it because you know he was
just thinking man what the [ __ ] all
examine why did you call me up he was
like I don't want to deal with your
[ __ ] you do it pay me imma give you
this you do yeah so he so he whips out a
huge saying of sage which he carries
around for just such emergency yeah it
looks like you good wait he's like I got
this big wad of sage right here and you
just burned this and like say go away
evil spirit or whatever got that from
the hippie segment of town I guess he
did and he got it full-on is only
whenever you go where the head shops at
hippies are hanging out they got one of
those facilities vile the stage yeah
yeah which that must be the leaf haunted
played really hard but they're perfect
yes sandal so the mom does the sage what
you call it and it appears to work
temporarily I think they said that for
three months Cody started acting like
normal Cody again that is like Apple
possess police yeah okay
but because you know that they're still
the episodes only like half over you
know it's just going to throw this so
you know it never works the first time
no man worse is that it usually does so
basically three months that everything's
fine the kids acting normal blah blah
blah so then actually a bris the halfway
point so what do you take a short break
right now it's going to be a much
shorter break than usual alright and
then we'll come back and talk about the
rest of the episode with Cody and man
yeah that sounds kinky good I mean go to
jail for odie and madmen not good
em a white window it rhymes and
everything okay so we're things start
break we'll be back in just a bit
you
clock fans love the show but don't have
an hour to spare check out our new list
Channel 13 o'clock in minutes all the
fun creepy topics of the main podcast
but in easy to swallow bite-sized pieces
links in the description more videos to
come soon
[Music]
[Music]
you
okay talking about Cody in the man yeah
that won't come back a 70 sitcom come on
in a man yeah well what was that one
checking on demand yeah man I used to
watch out my grandma yeah man I was on
YouTube and I saw a compilation of old
70s series you know the little theme
songs yeah the little open I forgot
there were so many bad shows but oh
they're really where I remember I was
like peek Lady Gaga Lady and Jeff I
can't really you know that was it was
like a little jet weren't they Japanese
that happenes you know pretend like you
were famous Japanese like pop singers or
some yeah but that'll be they were they
were just such a that was just a story
oh yeah I don't know you're everywhere
I'm sitting there just you know like 70
skinny coke or tech yeah everybody look
so gorgeously then yeah I watch a lot of
74 movies because I love 74 movie cast
girls but Harry I'm like how can they be
that skinny with us okay it must have
been coke okay oh yeah how's that way
naturally that skinny they were not
naturally this game ah nah it's
terrifying
so three months goes by then all of a
sudden the mom is walking down the hall
doing laundry just like women on the
show always do as we pointed out our
extra which go give us the money on
patreon and you can listen to or talk
about this they're always doing women
always be doing laundry on this show
yeah so she's doing laundry and Cody's
played in the hall laundry is a time for
most no type of ghost attack I get it I
see I didn't realize that was a thing
know that he is a woman doing laundry
cuz now's the time to strike now is when
women are at their most vulnerable
home [ __ ] it's all [ __ ] around too
much you gotta get me getting no it's
funny it's my heart all right so so
Cody's playing in the hall play with
fire trucks go and we even make an
annoying kid noises and then all of a
sudden he starts talking to man again
yes and you can see it like the
actresses face she just makes it [ __ ] my
life oh yeah this is one of the best
parts of the episode
actually I'm enema yeah not yet now like
if this really happened this would be
creepy as [ __ ] yeah
I don't know if it really happened or
not but if it did need to be creepy I've
got certain ideas maybe what happens in
it so then like she hears him talking to
man she comes out and she keeps calling
his name but he won't answer like he's
staring off into space
and he won't answer yeah so she like
runs up to I know including what's wrong
in his hand
the photograph yeah there's a photograph
and it is
and she said curly what you got here and
she pulled the photograph I don't and II
don't - my mommy starts with oh yeah and
going a go ahead talking it's okay let
me look at the mother and she looked at
the photograph of a little boy or old
late and it's all pull away from you 62
the pitch yeah she said fifty years it
was like an old horse who said was this
man and then she's like where did you
get it from hit man gave it to me Oh
which can you imagine like oh my god can
you imagine if we had five year old kid
and left suddenly that like a [ __ ]
picture appeared and right and you
didn't know where it came from front
like man gave me and he was just sitting
there were they doing that creepy it
really went down that way I would say
that that would get some credibility to
this case I have to know where the photo
came from there's a possibility that the
kid earlier on maybe the day before was
walking around and maybe a letter just
not let her a photograph just blew by or
maybe even digging in the garbage and
found a photograph and he thought to
himself that must be man
yeah that's easily got angry - yeah but
that's not how we're being told this day
I went down we're being told that
everything was normal
and then all of a sudden she just
notices in there in a trash in his hand
cut that you're a man where did that old
man gave it to me as if man appeared you
know I mean yeah came through a
dimension door you know noon with a
photograph and goes check this out kid
thank you that was a bit weird you can't
be thumbs gestures right now I was there
very funny he's doing the mom I don't
know I don't know which way it happened
the episode is leading me to believe
that it happened as if man gave it to
him right then disappear only had for a
few minutes right because he may have
had that although yeah like you said the
kid could have found it earlier pretty
much anywhere and been tricked and been
carrying it around like in his pocket or
something and nobody
and then he maybe he thought of he
thought word man and he's like oh it's a
little kid and I got back there it is
right as I found it right so we don't
know yeah we don't know but like I said
that baby I think probably more likely
that he found it on his own
yeah and he assumed that that was man
because why because he found it if he
found it then it's man well yeah and
gave it to him cuz he found it yeah
that's how little kids think well yeah
because they think the whole world
revolves around right right they're not
going to be like well I found this
random photograph and I don't know this
person right you know so I'm gonna throw
the float away no that's not how it is
yeah I found this photo there's
something it's important because about
it yeah and his little boy in it that
must be man that's yeah I imagine that's
probably the growing area right yeah so
after that the kid starts acting like a
bottle again he starts to like his nanny
is trying to give him lunch and stuff
like that and he has another little
tantrum where he just like sweeps the
lunch off as he was I don't why stupid
lunch oh and then like his mom comes in
as like Cody with the mug and then like
the kid like pushes his mom down yeah
and he's like but man do anything you
guys and he's like that i MLG Fred ha ha
ha and at this point the nanny goes [ __ ]
this are out yeah right
the nanny quit yeah and she's like you
know get that kid some counseling and I
was like yeah I agree right but they
never do so now like the the mom is
coming to you can yeah it's like stuck
in this position of like well now I have
to find somewhere to stick this kid
while I'm at work so the first place she
takes them is to now they said it was a
distant cousin so I guess it was like a
relative of theirs that lived nearby and
she had a daughter it was around the
same age as Cody and this relative I
don't think they named her know the
little girl's name was chaotic so this
this lady says okay well I can take care
of Cody for a little while until you
find another daycare so the mom sells
Cody now I'm going to take you to what's
her name's house and don't take man with
you okay he's yummy now they man at home
so she takes the kid to the house and
then she goes to work now a little while
later she gets a phone call from the
relative
and the relative is freaking out and
she's crying as if she says come get
dinner head right now come yeah come get
him out of here come and get him out of
here yes she shows up a woman in the in
the episode the woman is already
dragging the kid out dragula kid out
there likewise about it I don't take him
like what happened so she's like she
says what is wrong with him
yeah yeah she's like my kid is in there
freaking out crying I'm crying and then
it shows yeah like a little flashback of
what happened of what happened now the
woman is in the house like picking up
toys or whatever and this is according
to the mom they didn't have this woman
on yes like program so there's no
correct writing when table lady wait a
minute
we're not provided with witness yes but
this is what the mom said that this
other woman was she said she was in the
living room picking up toys and she
heard Kody and the little girl were in
the bedroom he said I heard a voice and
she's like for a second I thought it was
Kobe talking in another voice it was
like a man's voice like it was a really
deep voice yeah and then the daughter
screamed so she ran and opened the door
and she saw Kody and the little girl
standing in the middle of the room and a
bunch of toys floating in the air above
them right and then as soon as she saw
it they fell they found on the ground
it's about what's what was what was
shown or what how it was pictured was
six or seven fairly large objects yeah
you got foot tall each one of them Oh
Satan's oh yeah he fell to the floor
simultaneously and the little girl was
like crying which you know really sounds
like poltergeist manifestation what kind
of stuff that I saw if it should happen
the way it happens and that probably
what it was I don't like it was a demon
or nothing like that yeah so after at
that point she's like she has to take
the kid home and she's like look I told
you not to take man why did you do that
and all this other stuff and actually
going to call other places and she finds
another daycare to take him to and then
she insists it's time to really I'm
serious you can't take man to the
daycare and evidently he doesn't because
she take him to the next day care and
everything is fine but the it's funny
because the voiceover on the show says
at night man waits for him to come home
he's way Rubick
home from daycare so he can make him act
like like it as a llamar yeah so then
there was other [ __ ] too there was um
the next thing one evening the dad
raccoon man Danny comes up the stairs to
tell Cody it's time for dinner and Cody
is cutting up one of his teddy bears
yeah that's right kinda dies we didn't
worry cut up your toys because man said
and be fun me and kid it would be quiet
man said I could go downstairs and the
teenage daughter is like we head to my
cat and Cody was just sitting there on
the couch with the crazy look on his
face you the get up you know they he was
sitting on top of the kid yeah he put
the kitten underneath the couch cushion
and then just on like you're trying to
suffocate he was trying to kill the
kitty yeah yeah and I'm telling you
right something right now if I had a
five year old kid and they did that's my
cat I did is going yeah
don't you dare doing Bernie my guys
don't dare hurt my cat yeah cast I like
cats better the kid I don't and then we
know I think the next major thing after
that was the closet right yeah oh that
was the next day so at this point you
know the teddy bear I guess wasn't such
a huge deal because boys
ooh boy like anyway stairs [ __ ] I get
tired their tours they do Mike I have
two brothers dated that day they you
know and I used to actually my parents
actually serve run a daycare I tried to
blow up my Millennium Falcon with a
bunch of firecrackers one time we yeah
go yeah my brother blew up all his GI
Joes with yeah whoa ba Baracus yeah she
I would shoot stuff with shoot my toys
with her BB gun and I'm right at her BB
gun and we had a dart gun off yet you
wished she'd look at that yeah so but
then you know him sitting on the cat
trying to kill the cat and then he made
like the little actor that was playing
the kids like made the best face ever
like Frank yeah and like this really
like a snuggly whiplash can it look he's
like yeah check out the last words I
can't
that's really funny about his phases
really you could see the whole time we
try not to laugh we're at 70 horrible
evil tantrums in it you know so that
seems like some serial killer [ __ ] right
there but like the mom was crying about
though so you're trying to do again
we're going to do both on
like um put him in at home I don't know
but they didn't do it so then the next
day or the next teen or whatever and
then they show the mom and she's trying
to clean up Cody's room and he's just
sitting there like a bomb and she's
saying you know you're in old enough
where you can help me out around here
close up and blah blah and she's digging
around in his closet and everything was
way everything is wet generic really
Cody are you peeing in your closet then
I sit out there on the bed like yeah why
are you peeing in the globe man said I
could ya need to change loleris
incidentally man said I could is like
the best that used for anything for him
we still use it like again you know why
would get in trouble for something hey
man said I could no fair enough fair
enough yeah he was peeing all of his
toys this toy box peeing over his own
clothes I guess he was wearing them too
yeah I'll pee on this and wear it I
thought he was marking a scout me make
my signature wherever I go yeah make
other people enjoy it too a man again
rescuer man right here everyone will
know I've been here in a Cell we know
all about this message do it well that's
what I'll do it well hunter is going
Drexel's a deer pissed about it matter
of five-year-old boys not that far
removed from an animal known or not
that's why I think they put I mean I
guess they did it in chronological order
like the peeing incident I'm like that
sounds pretty much like a regular boy
that encode I got the teddy bear I'm
like yeah big deal yeah I was like like
I said I have no Q I can't
yes years I'm gonna have gasoline oh my
go
play with your gasoline I love it my
brother did them yes
but yeah so long you go go in there and
steal it from your dad's lawn mower what
is on fire David oh my mr. peel or your
auntie Green Springs ah yeah yeah Dom
Southerners wouldn't know what mr. Pibb
was they have mr. Pibb everywhere no
they do now I think in the day it was
only so maybe they don't that knee high
yeah I've seen me high teaching no I
don't think well did they still make me
not even I haven't seen it and it's not
like a youth I feel like the orange the
greatest nastiest uh fail okay let's go
get extra study so uh you know she's
like you know you pee in the bathroom
not the closet Dom you know you're five
and then he has another Walter I'll have
to listen to you anymore
man settle after with you yeah yeah so I
have I have like always really great
like Nadia Kosovo I'll be cool if India
cool defense just for an adult you get
hauled into court for like a bar brawl
red I don't listen to you
cops show up man said I could hear on
copper and they're like okay I said it
okay yeah I both the man said ah yeah
it's like the Twinkie defense but even
better yeah at this point like I said
he's still acting like a brad panel over
everything now
then there comes one particular night
where the mom and the dad are sleeping
or whatever and then Cody comes into
their room and is acting like normal
Cody and he's all scared and showing
they're like mom mommy
my bed is shaking yes and he's like
getting scared and he's like apparently
he's over man at that point he's just
kind of like this is [ __ ] up and I
like even though I was having fun peeing
on everything and got my toys and
whatnot and getting away with [ __ ]
because man said I caught it evidently
even Cody could use a madman was getting
out of hand
and getting out of hand so she lets the
kids sleep in the bed and then she says
okay well I'm going to see what the [ __ ]
is going on so she leaves Cody in the
bed and she goes down and lays down on
Cody's bed she's like I wanted to see
what was going on with this kid in his
room now she says or the food what they
showed the reenactment so she's laying
on the bed like waiting to commune with
man I guess and then she sees like a
silhouette in the doorway which at first
she thinks is Cody because it looks like
a little boy but I'm assuming in the
show they were saying oh it was like the
little dead kid that they thought it was
the beginning or hour and so she's like
Oh Cody c'mere and then she hugs the kid
and apparently while she's hugging the
kid the kid starts growing yes into a
big ropey naked dude this all painted
white looks kind of like a war boy from
sure yes actually but yet kinda like
that
actually he looked like that guy that we
knew from El Salvador no I'm calling it
Jacob look like Jacob did kind of look
like Jacob gonna put a picture Jacob
there next yeah Jacob was this Colombia
guy who's a goth guy who was on a couple
of South American television shows never
yeah and he would always play somebody's
boyfriend or something that he looked
just like that he dressed up as a
vampire or a demon with huge wings and
cloven hooves
yeah and he okay you act up and really
cool outfit and he did a suspension like
the benches where they put hooks to the
piercings in your back and you up and he
flies around Linda's oh yeah he was also
a tattoo artist he did Jenny's sweep
yeah he did one of my that season my own
but yeah he looks just like this he did
yeah now that you mention he didn't look
like that
we should ask how he was in a hospice
ode so old it was like so many years
yeah okay so apparently the mom has now
seen man and you know and it's like
trying I don't know if they implied it
like kind of trying to bring through
something but that you know no man but
it was kind of like tumor and she was
like and she was like screaming and [ __ ]
like that and so like her whole thing
like I'm drying out as well what the
[ __ ] are you screaming at and they
didn't she didn't really tell the dad or
the daughter she does she just didn't
look like I mean she just I mean maybe
she is later but on the reenactment she
was kind of like
nothing whatever but she said she
finally understood but then Lego is gone
yeah like then Cody was standing there
and then he came over and like grabbed
her hand and she said that he gave me a
look like see ya oh boy
Cody with her man wasn't a little boy it
was this demonic man yeah it was a deep
yeah thank you my guy right so she
called the shaman back again and she's
like hey that [ __ ] you said before um
yeah well it didn't work he said well it
didn't work because it's your fault
because cuz you're one me and you can't
do anything right you can't even wave
that around why I just wasn't specific
enough yeah
so because the first time that she did
the sage was the eternal she was trying
to kick out what she thought was a
little dead kid that was causing there
about it well that's not one of the
demon and particularly yes to be
particularly specific when you're doing
this kind of ritual that the one that
you the one thing that you want out of
your house because if you say hey I want
the vampire out of my house
or hey I want this specific spirit out
of my house all the other ones will say
oh well I guess we can stay then cool
bro so they just pick anger fest you
know again she has to do it by herself
she sends everybody off to work school
etc rook gets out the sage olive oil and
then olive oil yet where she okay was
pouring a lot of olive oil now yeah and
I reunite I was like again wait a man he
must have a gallon of that I was like do
that extra virgin olive oil that's just
not cheap don't waste that yeah he's
made me get a great lot of it death well
the weird thing that too is that she was
pouring it you think that you would want
to pour it like around the perimeter of
the house
she was just pouring well she came in
the doorway like several feet and then
she poured like a line of it I'm like
are you not just like trapping the demon
in the house I bet you wanted to get in
there how can I leave I don't know I
mean I don't know I don't understand how
the ritual it's a ritual you don't need
too much into it because it doesn't have
anything to do with it so that's how a
ritual would work if a ritual actually
work it wouldn't have anything to do
with mechanics of the ritual it would be
because it's building you up safe as you
believe that yes
making up your willpower to make
something happen yes my fellow ma you
basically yeah or you know ot powers
from Scientology by others do they
imagine things happening and they
imagine things to do is it funny that
every time I think of ot powers and I
hope somebody knows what I'm talking
about if you guys ever watched kids in
the hall back in the 90s
every time somebody talks about ot
powers I always think of Tom Cruise
doing that sketch from kids in the
hallways I'm touching your head I'm
crushing her head like hearing it from
far oh yeah
I don't know why those two things get
associated to me what they did you guys
I'd be a cool horn name what oh my god
oh my god that's the best idea because
now we can do like a whole series of
Scientology singing porn
yeah well T powering OT powers ot powers
he's a Tom Cruise gay look like yeah any
porn look-alike oh yeah you're a genius
where's the sailor outfit and everything
just like right out of right out of the
yeah well York oh and you had work out
and yeah yeah yeah I like this idea yeah
I'm going to write a series of erotic
novels they'll be a Tom Cruise darkness
I can't stand Tom Cruise oh really
I can't stand looking at his stupid face
I'm not going to talk about about Tom
Cruise because I actually like Tom I
think it's good actor oh he's good in
the right movement in certain movies
yeah you know I liked him in some movies
but I actually like him interviews
they're part I did too you like though
he was Tom Cruise I like him and I liked
him in the Top Gun I thought he and I
said he was convincing fighter pilot
well I think he was a convincing
douchebag over there really the best
thing I thought man was I think it was
Magnolia
okay because he was actually playing
against pipe and he didn't seem like the
best Tom Cruise movie that I've seen
with the sci-fi movie where he realized
that he was a claw it was never we saw
that one yeah why can't I roll in iam or
some eleni eleni eleni
old people can't remember why they put
fake words on these movies you know an
actuary owned and [ __ ] like well and
everything sounds like some kind of a
it's kind of like how nowadays a child
this functionality you know take 30
milligrams of uranium remember when that
drug came out I can't wear what it's
Corbett was called otezla and I was like
dad look I was like that sounds like
something to Mayans would be sacrificing
yeah otezla yeah well I hate that
because all these like new businesses
that are coming out they're like well we
want to build up our own brand in our
own story so we don't want a word that
has any prior association so we have to
make up a word right but that really
doesn't work out so good because then
all the words become kind of similar
like Ivana and and like I can't tell one
from the other and that actually keep in
the 70s yeah seventies marketing
thinking you know are they made 70s and
80s they were making up car names yeah
like what is a Corolla a Corolla isn't
anything it's just a Toyota yeah you
know yeah no such thing as a Corolla oh
yeah innovated word you know and company
is as fake as Corinthian leather i
encoder whoo yeah horn really known for
leather
yeah that's not leather that's vinyl
core not really no upper file
yeah that's where the vinyl cows yeah
everyone knows that
so really the fun like we mentioned
before actually break for Michigan well
that'd be that's definitely get away
with this tomorrow morning billion yeah
I'm sure that's delegate all right good
all right so basically the last 10 15
minutes of this episode is this poor
woman run around the house pouring
expensive olive oil
waving sage everywhere with a feather
yeah and the cameraman going apeshit
trying to make it look like something's
happening right now and Jake the camera
shaking the camera like anything at all
rotating at all crazy camera weighs less
than the house yes I'm on camera I never
thought of it that way above Yorker I
get yeah so it's yeah it's kind of like
on the old Star Trek when they said okay
well we're going to hit something so
everyone fall over it
yes sir guys overacted it doing
backflips yeah but well shat shat the
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm gonna hold on hold on
yeah yeah rock back and forth and he
could you tell he's getting sick of it's
like I feel like I actually dork right
now oh we should mention like last night
because sometimes when were bored we
kind of go on YouTube and try to find
with old shitty 70s movies and we
watched one last night called nightmare
at 30,000 feet
Oh bad Carol yeah it's really heavy shat
within it and the shot was in it it was
an old all-star cast it really was like
it was it was one of the 70s movies I've
ever seen and it was like a stupid
premise I guess it was like a plain but
it wasn't like a plane crash type of
movie there was like they were
transporting some old piece of fiction
or a B years of Atlanta B and it was
demons or druid gods or some [ __ ] and
they started like possessing people on
the plane and like maybe a cold eye and
I was like any elite 747 airplanes like
a flying hotel and it cost a lot of
money to fly on it yeah they got caught
into a tailwind with 600 miles an hour
but they weren't going any fast so the
plane was basically suspended in air
while we were getting attacked with it
by a demon driving and the Shatner
played the he was reached with he
defroster he did rock way to quit
creased and he was like an exhibit the
most cynical cynic the ever cynic yeah
in any movie ever and a drunk so Annie
Annie saved that movie he did yeah he
what he was really the best part of that
movie he was like such a dick but he was
so awesome and spoiler alert he gets
sucked up the plane again yeah it's cool
in a very bad dream and when I spin at
the end when he finally sees the demon
it plays a Star Trek's out of the film
yeah it did ever Kirkwood see something
was [ __ ] up in a video I don't know my
voice can't mimic that musical but you
guys Star Trek pencil no but it was
hilarious because they just lifted it
right from Star Trek and you can tell
they do that on purpose yeah this'll be
really funny yeah probably laugh his ass
off with the appropriate age regard he
had I feel like he had it when he didn't
did he get sucked out of it when he gets
sucked out of a plane instead of having
him actually getting sucked out it's
just a cut out photograph of the
yeah my Eagle over a shot of the glass
is the bad the worst sizes though it was
the worst special but I ever but it
worked but it's very unfunny I do
recommend it it is but it should be just
because it's there bad [ __ ] and then
there was that woman in there that
looked kind of like Mira Ferro but not
yet it was like me it was like totally
around a sexy little chicken white go-go
boots the the British yeah like those
unbelievable [ __ ] stewardess I would
happen feeling like how many four super
short skirts and like white go-go boots
yeah yeah and like a thing on their head
that looks like a helmet crash helmet
yeah 37,000 would nightmare at 30,000
feet or so yes 37,000 feet I think is
what it was called and you can watch it
for free on yeah we thought we found it
on YouTube too kind of came across it it
was thanked for TV Emily yeah because
there was like gasps oh there was
commercial but yes I was like super fun
and uh okay so anyway last last couple
of minutes of the episode like I said
wishes blah blah and apparently they
showed like a whoosh like the demon was
like [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah stage and
olive-oil drive up a most vile vilest of
demons but right evidently yeah although
they did say afterwards now apparently
yada yada everything went back to normal
they were all eating cookies and drawing
and happy and everything like that but
then they shared the mom said well we
still hear noises every now yeah we're
so worried resins when it comes and goes
so I don't know if that was just like a
haunting thing which you can't leave it
like with a happy ending you have to say
oh maybe it'll come back no I think I
think what the whole deal was her so
there was no demon well obviously she
saw an apparition
oh if you did you look at the case in
its entirety I would say that it was
poltergeist
there would be the most likely you have
little kids it's generating apologize
based on his fears yeah okay and that's
it because and I said it's just because
there were claims that they saw objects
kind of levitating and just falling and
I looked at him that's that consistent
with some poltergeist activity
scratching on the walls yeah that's very
timely poltergeist it didn't seem to
have anything to do the location of
where the kid was yeah because it
happened
other people have other places right so
the kid seems to be the focal point of
it I would just have to say if this is a
real case it's poltergeist which I don't
know something happened I believe the
testimony of the husband and the wife it
sounded like they believe it but how can
you how can you do bunk acting
cross-check it yeah guys like I said I
don't know what the real names are they
didn't know their faces all you can see
they didn't disguise their forces but
right you know I don't know who they are
they won't tell you their and I'm not
really even sure if that's the sound of
bomb or anything raw that they might've
and it was something that was happened a
while back or a long time ago yeah so
would be difficult to go back and verify
it yeah well like I said if it doesn't
find the kid I know baby that still
happens around him yeah cuz not actually
they didn't talk to the kid oh no no a
daughter yeah no that has got it yeah
cuz usually they get the whole family in
on it he didn't want to talk about it
maybe not and also the sister didn't say
anything about it now it wasn't yeah it
is pretty weird um so did did man say
that we can end the show now needed to
change man said we could okay so so for
the YouTube listeners like I said
YouTube it'll just be the same if you
want the audio podcasts and go to our
WordPress page which is wordpress.com
and slash certain reporter window on
patreon please support the show on
patreon we have like a lot of really fun
extra stuff on there so far and we're
going to put some more stuff up in the
big earner the bigger the patreon
results the more effort we will put in
the show we will make it even better
show you guys all of it so that's what
we're kind of aiming for so please go
and check that out we also have t-shirts
at zazzle.com
slash 13 o'clock and is that it yes I
think that's it this was episode 50 can
you believe it yeah yeah you can get a
good
yeah we've been doing our promise in two
weeks it'll be our year anniversary of
doing the show cool so yeah maybe we'll
do something special for that because I
have another two weeks to plan on what
man says me and Jay it would be slided
yeah that's we have to consult man
before we can do anything yeah so we say
bye and man's does by five
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you